fyk là et c'est là on appelle aussi la
maladie de lou gehrig cette terrible
maladie dégénérative qui s'attaque aux
nerfs moteurs et qui paralysent peu à
peu la personne touche 3000 canadiens
ici à radio canada c'est un peu devenu
la maladie de bruno notre collègue
réalisateurs dont patrice roy vous a
longuement parlé l'an dernier comme la
plupart des malades de là et c'est la
brune aubenas migaud a fait le choix de
vivre sa maladie chez lui avec les siens
et si nous avons décidé de vous donner
ce soir de ces nouvelles c'est que son
cas illustre bien les limites des soins
à domicile au québec et les défis
immenses auxquels sont confrontées les
familles
atteint de la sclérose latérale
amyotrophique bruno bon amigo a décidé
de vivre sa maladie chez lui pour être
auprès de sa femme et de ses deux
enfants
en faisant ce choix il ne pouvait pas se
douter des conséquences au quotidien que
cela allait entraîner
bruno a été réalisateur pendant de
nombreuses années à radio-canada
afghanistan haïti il a couvert toute
l'actualité internationale avant de
devenir coordonnateur du téléjournal 18
heures c'est en septembre 2011 qu'il
reçoit le diagnostic coup de poing qu'un
moi flammarion me faire l'annoncé comme
bons mais j'étais finalement mon numéro
est sorti quand je pense à mes enfants
et à ma femme je vais beaucoup
l'impression de les abandonner ce pour
moi ça n'était qu'un supporter il faudra
réadapter toute une partie de la maison
bruno doit le faire avec l'aide de ses
amis et de ses proches parce que les
services promis par québec n'arrive
jamais assez vite
les installations seront rapidement
délaissé
parce que moi d'où 2011 faisant corps du
vélo de la natation au mois de septembre
était diagnostiquée sa peau était lente
peu après la can la marche est fauteuil
roulant en janvier trois mois traité
déjà fauteuil roulant reste à la maison
oui société clair depuis le début mais
qu'est ce que ça voulait dire on n'a
jamais eu pas vraiment de passer ou pas
c'est une étape à l'autre rapidement
il gît corps m
n o p p sur la position
deux ans après le diagnostic bruno est
prisonnier de ses records mais son
esprit reste intacte
il peut encore dire oui avec un
mouvement des yeux et peine à s'exprimer
une lettre à la fois et en août avait
fait le choix de vivre sa maladie à la
maison est-ce que c'est toujours ce que
tu souhaites continuer à pouvoir vivre
chez toi oui
parce que tu saufs
voilà c'était ok
sachant cela trachéo c'est douloureux ce
que c'est physique ou la souffrance
parce que c'est physique
ouais vivre sa maladie à la maison
entraîne la visite d'une armée
l'intervenant une préposée le matin cinq
fois par semaine
médecins ergothérapeutes
physiothérapeutes massothérapeutes
infirmières
une aide qui vient en partie du système
public mais aussi beaucoup de leurs
assurances privées et si loin d'être
suffisant le docteur serge daneault a
accompagné plusieurs patients atteints
de la sla
il déplore les limites des soins à
domicile
on a peut-être l'impression en voyant ce
reportage que ce patient et garder mais
pas du tout il ya l'essentiel est
peut-être qu'un certain niveau est là
pour avoir plus et mieux pour assurer
une fin de vie qu'ils soient adéquats ce
que je te croise des gens
ce qui explique peut-être qu'au québec
seulement 10% des malades vivent leur
fin de vie à domicile
un des taux les plus bas en occident
alors qu'il en coûterait deux fois moins
cher de garder ses patients comme bruno
à la maison plutôt qu'aux institutions
probablement que lui et son entourage je
voudrais pas quelques 24 heures à la
maison mais ça coûterait moins cher de
consentir comme société à ce service là
qui est le service ce qui au fond que
d'hospitaliser cette patiente dans un
hôpital de soizic et d'un code des
personnes qui vont qui sont en fait vie
c'est la dernière chance que nous avons
bien faire et on ne peut pas mettre des
délais parce que la maladie elle ne
connaît pas de télé 2 3 co or le manque
de soins c'est surtout julie la
conjointe de bruno qui en paient le prix
plus la maladie progresse plus tout
retombe sur ses épaules aucune aide le
soir la nuit ni les fans semaine une
vigilance constante 7 jours sur 7 qui
l'épuisent au début ce qui était dit
c'est moi je continue à travailler et
lui il est à la maison mais plus en plus
la maladie progresser
l'opl laquelle choix la maison plus
souvent alors
j'ai pu avoir un arrêt de travail de
presque même peine
même pas souci c'est pour ces pour
beaucoup j'aurais pu avoir pour moi je
pensais pour les aidants naturels on
devrait avoir beaucoup plus que ça
est-ce que tu des regrets parfois non je
peu de regret mais cessé de se faire
beaucoup de deuil ou de projets qui
peuvent pas voir une chose
je pense qu'elle est fatiguée aussi par
de pointe à la hauteur par deux de faire
des erreurs
des patients soit j'aime beaucoup c'est
vraiment ce sursaut 26
vous nous juste pour que ce soit clair
ce que ça prend pour rester à la maison
ça prend plus de soins pour aider plus
dead pour alléger un peu la tâche des
jurés est ce que c'est ça que ça prend
oui
le message que tu veux passer
veux te dire quelque chose je vais y
aller avec les lettres de l'alphabet
regarde en avant a b c des quais
deuxième lettre
il faudra près de 15 minutes à bruno
pour finalement nous faire comprendre ce
qu'il veut qu'on sache à v un appel à
l'aide à son équipe médicale mm comme
myriam message message non
est-ce que c'est leur message on
continue la deuxième date on oui ce
serait un message il y avait écrit
peut-être un message
est ce que c'est ça pour nous oui
est ce que c'est le mal que tu as essayé
d'écrire cette semaine avec nicolas que
tu me montres qui ne vouloir tout de
suite
un message qu'il a intitulée sos comme à
écrire ça ma femme est presque au point
de rupture le soir à les somnambules
lorsqu'elle me donne les soins elle fait
la traque et aux soins de la canicule
prépare les médicaments elle tombe de
sommeil de plus je la réveille plusieurs
fois par nuit
je sais que vous avez des infirmières de
rotation de soins
le soir
l'épuisement de julie lui est
intolérable
alors malgré le poids de la maladie
bruno tenait à lancer cette ultime
message pour elle et pour tous les
autres aidants naturels
à travers ça il tente de garder le moral
de sourire
ce que j'aime ce camp qui sourit car
vous nous sourire c'est drôle parce que
ça me souviens pauthe a aussi trouvé à
dire qu'elle est très loin d'être malade
et soupçonnent le sourire l'étape aussi
fréquent maintenant je trouve qu'ils
savaient beaucoup je sais bien
pourquoi qui sait peut-être c'est la
façon pour lui de montrer qu est
d'accord avant il disait maintenant
souvent voyais un sourire le dos et seau
un sourire qu'ils partagent et il prend
bien soin de rester impliqué dans les
petits détails du quotidien chez lui
jusqu'au bout
et
ah oui c'est ça
mais aucun témoin bordure
lui veut veiller pour prier laisser
aller mais c'est principalement pour
vous
il veut et clôt avec nous la plante
impossible